la salida de rayapaxa No termina con la
crisis los manifestantes volcados en las
calles exigen ahora la renuncia del
Primer Ministro biker m Singer Quién es
el presidente interino un Aliado del
depuesto presidente que nos dio a las
maldivas
[Aplausos]
Inge nos ha fallado como Primer Ministro
nosotros toda la gente no lo quiere como
presidente
el Primer Ministro quien anunció que
renunciaría cuando haya un nuevo
gobierno respondió con fuerza a los
manifestantes y trató de disolver las
protestas con más represión
debido a la situación de hoy las fuerzas
de seguridad me aconsejaron declarar el
estado de emergencia e imponer el toque
de queda debemos derrotar esta amenaza
fascista la oposición que se
autoproclama como el cambio que el país
necesita está en contra de las medidas
del gobierno
más grande
no solo condeno conveniencia estos
ataques a personas desarmadas que están
protestando sino que me comprometo a
derrotar esto con El poder del pueblo
las protestas en esta isla de Asia del
sur llevan meses y alcanzaron su punto
más fuerte el fin de semana cuando miles
de personas tomaron las residencias de
los líderes políticos sri lanka
atraviesa una de sus peores crisis con
una inflación galopante la escasez de
alimentos y la corrupción en el centro
de las denuncias los legisladores
acordaron elegir un nuevo presidente la
próxima semana pero el martes tuvieron
dificultades para decidir la composición
de un nuevo gobierno